that is genuinely the scariest thing I
have ever seen is that real and when are
they coming for me almost looks like
when in movies you see aliens coming
down to earth to dominate the planet yes
our number three epic stunt comes
courtesy of the grasp lab at the
University of Pennsylvania where some
clever people have unleashed this an
army of highly mobile seemingly
intelligent robot creatures this
internet smash has our experts
salivating on oh so many levels take
first the individual
quadrotors have four propellers that are
pulling it up and you can control the
speed of each of these and so when you
make two on one side go faster it pulls
out side up more which pulls it off in
that direction or vice versa and that's
how you can flip it and turn it and
control it the other thing is the whole
thing isn't rotating around the reason
it's not rotating around is because they
rotate two of them in opposite
directions so this causes kind of
counter rotational force very clever
very smart so that's what makes the nano
quadrotor capable of agile flight but
how can a swarm of them do this or this
one computer is directing the movements
of each of these robots and it's
functioning like the conductor in a
symphony telling each robot where to go
the room is outfitted with cameras and
the cameras are tracking the positions
of the robots at very high speed and
very precisely so this computer is
crunching numbers at an incredible rate
it's tracking the positions of the
robots in real-time and it's sending
commands to the robots at 600 times
every second and that is what's truly
astonishing how they've made this
program to give everything this amazing
synchronized effect